listen i gotta give you a standing
ovation my girl
princess switch three you're not only a
producer you're playing three characters
three love interests three story lines
and you know it just kind of gets my
brain thinking
about your brain mary queen
stacy yeah and that's margaret mm-hmm
well here we go again
can you remember maybe like a funny
story on set where you showed up you're
ready to go to work but you're like oh
my god who am i playing today what's
going on here i never really had the who
am i playing because the characters are
all so
specific and defined by
the way that they look um so i mean just
one glance in my reflection and i know
who i am but when you switch
but yes when they switch it was
definitely compute the thing that's most
confusing about it isn't doing it it's
talking about it so we would like sit
down and go over what we were doing that
day and
ah man i can't tell you the
conversations where it's like but it's
it's it's it's queen margaret being
fiona and then fiona
and then everyone says it differently
and it was just a disaster and it gets
to a certain point we're like we'll get
there when we get there nevermind
the movie ends with three happy couples
you know your fans of course want to see
what happens next
are we gonna get a princess switch for
um you know i never want to say never uh
but
i i definitely need a a break from
from
the amount of work that these movies
take they're like they're so special and
i i love being in everyone's home for
the holidays and knowing that it's
bringing families together just fills my
soul with joy uh but
it's a lot so i i take a minute okay
well you know i don't know how much you
keep up with what the kids are talking
about online but fans would just really
love to see a princess switch baby i
mean
if there was to be a fourth installment
i mean are you down to where the bump
and show the next uh iteration of this
story i feel like i would just want to
skip the bump part and just
be
me holding babies because god i love
babies
okay we'll keep our fingers crossed i
know it's a lot so maybe in a year or
two you'll revisit and give us some some
good news
um another thing i saw on the internet
that i absolutely loved fans are
affectionately referring to fiona me
as the british sharpay what are you
doing here i'm the new lifeguard
have you seen that
work no i haven't
i think it's so iconic and you know
they're obviously different but very
similar in many ways i can't go a day
without seeing gabriella memes and gifts
on social media high school musical it's
forever a beloved part of pop culture is
there a part of you vanessa that would
ever be open to revisiting the role of
gabriella maybe doing something a little
more adult i mean if it was adult i feel
like it takes away from what high school
musical is
um
i don't know it was such a beautiful
moment in time that so many people do
hold so close and near and dear to their
hearts it's scary to mess with something
like that because it is so beloved you
know even though it's still us
i i don't know i don't know
okay i respect whatever you want to do i
just want to let you know you could
never mess with anything i think seeing
gabriella grown up thriving in whatever
career she chose to do i think fans
would love to see it someone just got to
write a script and send it to all of us
and if we like it then who knows yeah
for sure
you know i also i just want to
compliment you it's been so wonderful
seeing
you step into this this world as a
producer obviously you're a
multi-talented uh triple threat you've
got cali water
and then the other night you go and you
make this beautiful red carpet debut
with your man cole
what has it been like sharing all of
these incredible experiences with your
guy yeah it's great i mean it's really
cute because i i during his season i've
i've gone to a lot of games way more
than i have
in my entire life condensed into a year
um and
and it's so fun like i love going and
supporting and cheering him on but
for the premiere days he's like it's
game day babe he's like it's so nice i
get to come to your game and i'm like
it's
yes
same thing um but it's great he's
amazing
yeah you know what what is it about this
relationship that feels different i see
you even just like kind of beaming right
now with this huge smile
um
it's just easy uh we're like the same
person
very much the same person but with
different interests so it's cool we have
the same spirit i think like we're both
just energetic we want to have a good
time easy
uh goofy
princess switch is pretty much a holiday
tradition at this point it's getting on
the couch watching you and these antics
going you know wild on the screen how do
you hope people feel now that
temporarily this this trilogy is kind of
coming to a close i mean i feel very
proud of it i it was like a little
nugget that started from my love of the
parent trapped and now we are on the
third and it's become this trilogy and
to be a part of another trilogy but know
that it was literally just dependent on
me because i was playing all the
characters it's really cool and it feels
like a really really special
accomplishment
where do you go from here i feel like
this was a tall order being part of a
trilogy like this are there more brain
child ideas kind of bubbling up that you
can tease
not that i can tease per se but i'll
just say like during during the lockdown
i think we all had more time than we've
ever had to sit still and be with
ourselves and i know for me that really
just gave me space to be creative um and
i was living with my best friend and the
two of us just kind of put our heads
together and we're like what do we want
to see what do we need to be doing um
and so all those things are
in motion it's really exciting just um
like
really getting in there and
being creative and dreaming things up
and
and now seeing them slowly start to come
into fruition
well with you queen the sky's the limit
i can't wait to see what you do next and
again standing ovation i watch this
movie in complete awe of how your brain
operates
uh yeah i i'm shook by it
[Music]
myself you